[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Thank you
for having me, first of all.
It's an honor to be here,
and I'm excited to do this.
I looked up some of the other
conversations that you've had,
and this is very cool
for me to get to do this.
JASON ANDREAS: Thank you.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: It
starts when I'm a kid.
I needed a job, and
I was 14 years old.
I grew up in--
I was born in
Brooklyn, New York.
And when I went to high
school, my parents,
we moved to
Somerville, New Jersey,
and that's where I
went to high school.
JASON ANDREAS: And
to clarify, Brooklyn
was very different back
then than it is now, right?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
Brooklyn, you know, the
cool parts of Brooklyn
today were parts
you weren't allowed
to go to when I was a kid.
You were shot and
killed, basically.
And now they're all really
high-end, super cool places.
But my dad was an attorney,
and he was the kind of guy
who just believed in
hard work and good ethics
and good morals, and you've
got to work for what you want.
And so there was this
stereo that I coveted,
and I wanted him
to buy it for me.
And he said, well, I'll
pay for half of it.
And I'm 14, you know,
making no money,
and my allowance was just
barely covering lunch, you know?
So he said, you
should get a job.
And I was 14, and I lied
to get my first job.
I told them I was 16 so
I could work extra hours.
And I was a dishwasher.
And as much as it
was hard work--
hot, sweaty, gross work--
I loved it.
There was a connection
to the guest,
and there was this interaction
between the staff that just
called me, and I just loved it.
And I worked in that restaurant
all through high school.
And they allowed me--
I remember, I'll never forget--
the bartenders were
old school bartenders.
They said, in order to
be a good bartender,
you have to read
two newspapers a day
so you can talk about sports and
politics and the stock market,
and you could have
a little something
to say about a lot
of different things.
And at the end of the night
when I was closing up,
they'd be sitting there
counting their piles of money,
and they'd say, hey, Michael.
Do you want to get behind
the bar and pour us a beer?
And I just thought
it was the greatest
honor to pour the
bartenders their beer
at the end of the night
while I was putting
glasses and whatnot away.
And that was sort of the start
of just being interested.
And I always was interested
in cooking, even as a kid.
I was a jock who
played all sports,
but I also loved cooking.
My mother and my
grandmother, great cooks.
And the kitchen was a very
central part of the house,
for sure.
JASON ANDREAS: I was going to
ask you-- sorry to interrupt.
I was going to ask you the
name of that first restaurant
if you recalled it.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Of
course, I remember it.
JASON ANDREAS: Well,
they hired a 14-year-old,
and they were also letting
you serve them beer,
so maybe we should leave
that off the record.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: No,
it's not there anymore,
so they can't get in
that much trouble.
JASON ANDREAS: So then
throw it out there.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: It was
called The Newsroom.
JASON ANDREAS: The Newsroom.
Oh, very appropriate.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: It was
called The Newsroom,
and it was the precursor to
what "Cheers" was, sort of like.
You walked in, and everybody
did know your name,
and they knew what you drank.
And you know, once I
got old enough to drink,
you know, you walked in
there, and whatever you liked
was sort of sitting at your
seat before you ever got there.
It was a special
place, and that's
what sort of got me going.
And I kept in touch with
the ownership there forever.
The owner was the
one that helped
me get into culinary
school, and I decided
that's what I wanted to do.
JASON ANDREAS: You
had mentioned too--
so you were a jock who was
also interested in food.
And I believe-- maybe you're
right at this fork in the road.
But you had the opportunity to
go on and play baseball, right?
And you made the decision to--
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Well, the
decision was made for me.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
OK.
Fair.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I was
a very good athlete,
but I got hurt also.
So I went to college and
I played ball in school,
but I got hurt.
And you know, listen.
There's a million people that
have a similar story to me
where they did decently as a
high school or college athlete
and got hurt, and
couldn't play any longer.
So I actually did-- the funny
thing is that the culinary
school that I went to called
the Academy of Culinary Arts,
you were allowed to take--
or you're not allowed, you
had to take extra classes
in a local junior college.
And you got all the sort
of rights and privileges,
if you wanted to be in a play
or you wanted to do something.
So I had gotten hurt, and I
really couldn't pitch anymore.
I was a pitcher.
But I could still
hit really well.
So I went out for the baseball
team at this junior college.
JASON ANDREAS: The ringer.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: And they
thought I was a joke, because I
was in the culinary
school, and they'd never
had anybody from the culinary
school try out for a team
before.
And they would tease me and say
things like, oh, what are you,
in the Betty Crocker league?
And I swear to God.
Or then they would tease me
and say, oh, in the summer,
you play in the continental
breakfast league?
And they would come up with
all these names for me.
And then I tried
out, and showed them
that I was actually a
really good baseball player,
and they wanted me
on the team then.
But you know, the whole thing
is when you're lucky enough
to find that thing, that if
you're going to-- you know,
work takes a lot of time
out of our day, obviously.
And when you find that
thing that just clicks--
and I hope people are lucky
enough to find that one thing.
I didn't know what I wanted--
my dad wanted me to
be a lawyer with him.
I didn't want to do that.
I had other friends
that said with the way
that I just sort of behaved
and whatnot that I should maybe
go into finance and economics.
I didn't want to do that.
I wanted to do something
that was creative.
And what I love about my job is
that it encompasses everything.
It's art.
It's history.
It's geography.
You're a cheerleader.
You're a psychiatrist.
You have to be a
business person.
You get to be an artist as well.
But at the end of the day,
you're taking care of people,
and you're teaching.
And that's the
part that really--
once I got to a certain
point in my career, that's
the part that I think sort
of gets me up every day
and makes it so exciting.
And plus, I get to deal with
lots of different cuisines.
So it's not like I'm only
making hamburgers all day long.
So I get to play around with
lots of different foods.
JASON ANDREAS: Well,
what was it for you?
You talked about this
idea of clicking.
What was it for
you that clicked?
Obviously, you were
in culinary school.
What was it for you that
drove you to say, OK, I want
to continue to pursue this?
And then ultimately,
you started working.
You toured, and you worked in
a lot of different restaurants.
Some of the best restaurants
around the country.
And then ultimately-- and
talk about that piece.
But also then, what took you
from maybe the next click that
took you from working in other
people's restaurants to now
your own?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So there's
several questions in there.
So the early part really is--
JASON ANDREAS: We like
multi-part questions here
at Google.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: And just to see
if I'm paying attention also.
JASON ANDREAS: You forget any
of the parts, I'll remind you.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So the
early part certainly
was that at a very
early age, I realized
that girls thought it was
cool that I liked to cook.
I could not play the guitar.
I really am not good with
mechanics and stuff like that.
But I can cook for you.
And that's how it
sort of started.
I started cooking for
girls I was interested in,
and they thought that that was--
JASON ANDREAS: That's as
good a reason as any, right?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
And it was funny.
I recently ran into an
old friend of mine--
not somebody I dated.
And she said, do you
remember that you
would come over in college and
make us omelets in the morning?
I was like, yeah.
I loved your roommate, you know?
I wanted her to like me.
So that was the start of it.
And I swear, that's
the real reason.
JASON ANDREAS: That's
a great story for her.
When I was in college,
Michael Schlow
would come over and
cook us omelets.
MICHAEL SCHLOW:
Exactly, you know?
JASON ANDREAS: Not bad.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: But
then there was something
that's sort of unspoken.
And you know,
whatever it is you do,
and when you find
your passion in life
and you're lucky
enough to realize
that this is that moment where,
this is the thing I want to do,
the light bulb goes off.
And you just think, what's the
real definition of success?
You know, is it how much
money is in your wallet?
I don't think so.
It's, are you getting
to do something
that you love every single day?
And do you wake up energized
every day to go and do this?
Because I do work
a lot of hours,
and my personal and
my business life
are really blended together.
But it has been a
fascinating life
that's given me the opportunity
to travel around the world
and meet some of my
heroes and cook for them.
And one of my great
passions in life
other than cooking
and my family,
obviously, is I love music.
And I've gotten to
meet some of my heroes,
and ultimately become
friends with some of them
and travel with them.
And I've just got--
I've had the most amazing
experiences because of it.
You know, as far as
what you were asking
about the restaurants and
the cooking and sort of how
it goes, some of it's just
dumb luck also, you know?
[LAUGH]
It is.
I mean, sometimes you're
just in the right place
at the right time.
And somebody doesn't
show up, and you
know, you think about that
path and how you move forward.
And sometimes you think, oh,
was this the right move for me?
But then you look at sort
of the cataclysmic jumps
of each thing that happens,
and it worked out for me.
It's been a bumpy road at times.
I mean, it hasn't just been
this beautiful line straight up.
There's lots of bumps in
there and restaurant closings
and a divorce, and there's all
kinds of stuff that's happened.
But that's what's
life, you know?
That's what makes
it interesting.
And then work hard and
come out on the other side,
and be successful.
But you know, I think the most--
not the most-- well, one of
the most important takeaways
is about good mentorship.
I was lucky enough to
have really good mentors.
They yelled and screamed at me,
which I don't do to my staff,
but it was a different time.
I would have food thrown
at me or screamed at.
JASON ANDREAS: Any
knives pulled on you?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Never a knife.
JASON ANDREAS: We've heard that
before at our Chefs At series.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I've
never had a knife pulled,
but I've had people
throw things at me.
And you just want to say,
you know, go fuck yourself.
I'm not staying here
for this, you know?
This is abusive.
And today's world
is about-- for me,
I learned a long
time ago that it's
got to be about teaching
and dedication, commitment,
and getting the people, the men
and women that work with me--
and they never work for me.
That's the big difference also.
I used to work for my chefs.
The people that work with me
work with me versus for me.
And it's just a
different approach
as to how to be a good teacher.
If you want to be a
good leader, you've
got to be a good teacher.
And if you want to
be a great leader,
you have to be a great teacher.
JASON ANDREAS: Why do
you think that's changed?
Because we've had a lot of
chefs who have come in here,
and they talk about chefs of old
like the Charlie Trotters who
used to scream and
yell and throw things.
And these chefs who would come
in and practice under them
and learn, they were terrified.
And now the chefs
that we have come in,
the most recent
ones we've had come
talk as part of the series,
it's more to what you're saying.
And it makes a lot of sense.
Why do you think that
was-- first of all, why
was it like that in the past?
I think we know why it changed.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Well, I
think I knew, because I used
to be a yeller and a screamer.
I came from that school,
and so I did the same thing.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: And I used
to have this internal message
to myself.
If I haven't made you cry yet,
you probably haven't heard me.
It was horrible, and
it's no way to live.
It's like, you're going to
give yourself a heart attack.
And there was this guy--
I was working in New York City.
I've worked a good portion
of my life in New York
before moving to Boston.
And there was a guy
who used to come
in every single day
for lunch by himself.
And he was just--
I think it was his
only moment of peace.
He would come and he'd eat lunch
in this restaurant by himself.
And one day I come
out of the kitchen,
and I'm all pissed off.
One of the young cooks was not
doing what I wanted him to do.
And the guy's reading
the newspapers.
His name was George.
I'll never forget him.
And he would always say to me,
I make decisions all day long.
You make the decision about what
I want to have for lunch today.
And he'll say fish, or chicken
or whatever, and I'd go back,
and I'd cook him something.
And so anyway, I
come out one day,
and I said, how was
your lunch, George?
And he said, it was
really delicious.
Thank you.
And he said, what's the matter?
You look upset.
I was like, ugh.
I don't even want
to talk about it.
I'm so pissed off right now.
This kid Shane, he's
not doing what I want.
I start ranting, and I'm
getting more and more worked up.
And he said, what
is Shane's job here?
And I said, well,
he's a line cook.
And I start sort of
just bitching about it.
And he said, well,
you're the chef, right?
And I said, yep.
And he said, well, I don't know
what you're so upset about.
It's your fault.
And I was young.
I said, my fault?
George, how can it be my fault?
I told him what to do.
He said, well, you're going
to learn this the hard way,
I'm sure.
And there's two ways.
You really have
two choices here.
Either train him to do his
job or deem him untrainable
and let him go.
But you can't let him go until
you've looked in the mirror
and say, I have done
every single thing
I know how to do to
train this person.
And I know it
sounds simple today,
but back then, it
was, again, one
of those light bulb moments
where I was like, you know,
he's right.
I need to change the
way that I'm training.
And I've been
working my whole life
on perfecting ways to train my
team, but not just train them.
Mentor them and
communicate to them,
meaning these four
basic pillars.
And I talk about
it every single day
to my executive team and the
people, the men and women that
are the GMs and the
chefs, because they really
hold all the power and all
the cards in the restaurants.
I can't be in 12
places at one time.
So I need to train you, mentor
you, teach you, coach you
that this is what we
want as a company.
And it's very, very simple.
It's tell, show,
practice, validate.
If you do those four
things yourself,
not give it off to
somebody else to do,
but as the person that is the--
whether it's the founder
or the keeper of the keys,
you know, the holder of all
the information, if you do that
and you do it 100%,
how can we have
any sort of miscommunication?
Or if they're not willing to do
those four things after you've
shown them and you've validated
that this is the way we put
the cup of coffee on the
plate or on the table,
and they want to go
outside those guardrails,
then they're not the right
person for your company,
and you have to let them
go, because it's not
fair to everybody else
that is doing it that way.
And it also will
lose the consistency,
which is the number one reason
restaurants are successful,
I think, or any business,
for that matter.
Consistency's everything.
But you know, to go back
to your original question
about why did it change,
it had to change.
It couldn't sustain itself,
this yelling, screaming.
You know, and also forget about
just court decisions and things
like that, the legalities of it.
It's just a different world,
and people won't tolerate that.
And also I think there's
another thing that's
sort of a crossroads, which is
there was a time when I would
have-- like at Radius, for
example, the restaurant you
were starting to talk
about earlier where
a lot of our awards came from,
I would have a stack of 20, 30,
40 people always willing to
work for free or for next
to nothing just
for the experience.
And as the restaurant
population has exploded,
and as retail has
gone e-commerce
so you don't have as many bricks
and mortar retail operations,
an incredible pressure's
put on our industry
to fill all those vacancies.
Banks, coffee, food and
beverage, and fitness.
Those are the four
things that are taking up
a lot of the retail space today.
You don't see people building
Macy's anymore, Lord & Taylors
or things like that.
It just doesn't happen.
And so as that sort of
changed, the pool of talent
became thinner and thinner.
And so again, we
go back to things
that we look at in our company.
And when we look at the
characteristics of what we're
looking for to hire somebody,
at no point in the seven or 10
key characteristics is
the word experience.
You don't have to
have experience
to come work with me.
But you have to be happy,
you have to be trustworthy,
you have to have a certain
amount of self-confidence.
You have to be
committed, dedicated.
Those are the things
I'm looking for.
I'll teach you how to carry a
tray or make a bowl of pasta.
But yeah, experience
isn't necessarily
the top thing for me anymore.
JASON ANDREAS: How
does that-- you
talked about the four pillars
and kind of these teaching
experiences.
You've got 11
restaurants, correct?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I think
something like that, yeah.
[LAUGH]
JASON ANDREAS: You have a lot
when you're not even sure.
I like that.
I wasn't sure too.
I was counting them.
MICHAEL SCHLOW:
Well, it's 11 or 12.
Depends on-- there's
this one restaurant
where we've split it in
half, and one side's Italian.
We have this little,
tiny restaurant,
and we have Japanese
next to it now.
It was a pop-up space.
JASON ANDREAS: How do
you apply these concepts
to kind of managing all--
again, you can't be
in all places at once.
You can't be in all these
restaurants at once.
How do you find the right
people to manage these for you
and kind of take some of these
kind of cultural aspects,
as you talk about it,
and sprinkle them down
through the business
from executives down?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
It's a team sport, I
mean, like anything.
In Boston, I would go into
the Apple store, for example,
and I would say, how is it that
I'm getting the same experience
at every Apple store?
Or how is it that you go into a
McDonald's and you get the same
experience at every McDonald's?
These are big companies.
JASON ANDREAS: That
consistency, right?
MICHAEL SCHLOW:
That consistency.
So where is it?
Like, what are we
not doing well,
and what are we doing well?
So we're a big fan of something
called appreciative inquiry
in our company.
And that is we look at
what we're doing well
and we try to
populate more of that.
It's easy to walk
into a restaurant
and say, that's wrong,
that's wrong, that's wrong,
that's wrong, and that's wrong.
That's what most managers do.
So compliment sandwich is a
big deal for us, you know?
To say, hey.
You're doing a great job.
Last night went so well.
We do need to do a better
job on whatever it might be.
And then you finish them
up with another compliment.
As I said, it's a team sport,
so I'm not by myself here.
We have a CEO, a CFO,
directors of operations.
And we meet on a weekly
basis, number one.
If we can't all be in the same
room, then we do a Google Chat,
a Google Meet.
So go Google.
It's changing my life, you know?
It really has.
I mean, I'm not
technologically advanced,
but Google is changing my life.
I'm not saying that
because I'm here.
It's the truth.
We have our CEO who
is a huge fan of all
the different Google
products, and he
has changed our company
in a way that we're all
communicating better.
So communication is still--
doesn't matter what business
you're talking about--
is the number one--
whether it's business or even
in your friendship or your love
life, communication's
always going
to be the number one
thing to help drive goals
and objectives.
So we do a couple of things.
We promote from within, which
is a very important thing to us.
If we can't find the
person from within,
there's probably a
chance that somehow,
some way, if we're
looking to the outside,
that person has a connection to
somebody on our executive team
often, if it's a top level job.
So it might be, hey,
we're looking for a new GM
at a restaurant and say,
you know who's looking?
I used to work with them at
such and such a restaurant.
I know they're really good, and
I think they'd be a good fit.
But you know, the
same could be said
for quite the opposite
where somebody says,
I know so-and-so's looking.
Don't hire them, because I
know they won't be a good fit.
You have to be cut from similar
cloth, I think, as far as--
not everybody brings the
same skill set, obviously.
And not everybody
has necessarily
the same experiences or in the
same place in their career.
But what we hope is that you
all have the same key ingredient
to being part of our
company, and that
is to have a
predisposition to serve.
And that's something we talk
about endlessly in our company.
Are you the type
of person to hold
that door open just a few
extra seconds for somebody
when they walk into
an office building?
Are you the type of
person to say bless you
to a stranger on the subway
who's sneezed, you know?
Are you the type of person
that says, excuse me,
you dropped this, and you
go chase after somebody
because they
dropped their scarf?
If you're not, and you're
that type of person
that when the elevator
door is closing,
and you're in a office building,
and you press it to close it,
I don't want you.
You know?
Yeah.
[LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: Google [INAUDIBLE].
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
So I want the one that
says, I'll hold that door.
We've all been in
those situations.
And you know what you do
and what you don't do.
And so, again, it goes back
to that inner monologue of,
did you do the right thing?
And the same thing can be
said about a hard day's work.
You know if you mailed
it in today or not.
Did you try your hardest?
And so those are the people
that we're looking for.
And if we can find the
sort of right human being
and then give them
the proper training
and the proper
guidance of what it
is that we want
from our company,
we can have a
consistent practice.
You can go into any
restaurant in the country
that we're involved
in and hopefully have
a similar experience.
There will always be a little
difference because of location
and there will be a
little difference because
of a management style
or what have you.
But overall, the sort of heart
of it needs to be the same.
And I think that's what
people come to expect.
That's why chains are
successful, or some chains are,
is that you know when you
go into McDonald's, you
are never going to get a
medium rare juicy hamburger.
It's never going to happen.
They all smell the same.
They all look the same.
Hopefully, they have salt
on their French fries.
I don't personally eat
a lot of fast food,
but when I go to look at
these-- and it's funny.
I'll go for research just to
see, have they changed at all?
And McDonald's-- I use
that as an example,
because it's the most
successful food company.
And if you think
about it, they've
tried at times to convince
us that somehow there's
something healthy there, right?
They're putting
salads and doing this.
But at the end of the day, what
do people go to McDonald's for?
They want a Quarter
Pounder with cheese.
You don't say, oh, I'm starving.
I want a salad.
Let's go to
McDonald's, you know?
You might get one
when you're there,
but it's not the first thing.
And so it's so
ingrained in your head.
So what we're trying
to do is obviously,
we're not that sort of size.
But what we're hoping to do
is that our company, when
you think of our
restaurants, you think of,
these are going to be
quality experiences.
I don't necessarily have to pay
an arm and a leg to go to them.
They're not on
the super low end.
They're not on the
super high end.
I have one restaurant
that's on the higher end.
But the rest of them are trying
to be part of a community,
and that's what's
interesting to me also.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, absolutely.
MICHAEL SCHLOW:
Which leads me to,
why did you come
to Detroit, right?
[LAUGH]
JASON ANDREAS: I didn't even
have to ask the questions here.
You just lead me on.
I like this.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Please, tell us why.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Community.
I mean, so we built this
restaurant in Birmingham
called Adachi.
And it was bred from friendship.
So what happened was one
of my partners in DC--
we have five restaurants
in Washington, DC.
And one of the partners
there grew up here.
And he had some
friends visiting him,
and they brought him to
some of our restaurants.
And they're developers.
They're hotel guys, and
they own parking lots,
and they own some restaurants.
But more like chain restaurants
and things like that.
They own gas stations.
They own cell phones.
They're like serial
entrepreneurs, these guys.
But they're really
nice, good guys.
So they come into
the restaurants,
and they look, and
they're like, wow.
Holy shit.
Like, this is what we want.
This is exciting.
It was one of my
restaurants called Tico.
And my wife is a
mixed media artist.
And my wife Adrienne went to
Tico and did all the painting,
did all the distressing
of the place.
Built these incredibly
super cool glass
panels that have her
artwork inside of them.
And she did it eight
months pregnant too,
so I'll never forget
that, and she'll never
let me forget that that
she did that work pregnant.
We have pictures of her,
like, on a ladder with a belly
out to here, and she's painting
and doing all this stuff.
But when you see the restaurant,
it's an exciting place,
and it's because of her work
that it was so exciting.
And when they came in to see
it, they immediately said,
this is something we would
love to see in Detroit.
Now we didn't want to
do Tico in Detroit.
The developers
were very specific
that they wanted a
Japanese-inspired restaurant.
So they said to me, you've got
Italian, you've got American,
you've got Latin
American, you've
got a California restaurant.
Have you ever done a
Japanese restaurant?
Oh, yeah.
Of course, we've done Japanese.
Which, I have not.
[LAUGH]
But I am of the attitude that
I'm not a master of everything,
but if I put my mind to it and
my heart to it, then I will--
and I had made food
like this before,
but never built a whole
restaurant around it.
So I had some
time, and I started
to work with some
people that I really
enjoyed working with, and just
learning some more techniques.
I had already worked with
these kinds of products before.
But when they said
Japanese, I said,
well, let's call it
Japanese-inspired,
so it gives us a little bit
of room, a little wiggle room.
And they allowed me to help
pick the designer, a woman named
Molly Allen from Washington, DC.
And if you haven't
been to Adachi yet,
it's a real push and
pull sort of experience
in that you go down South
Woodward in Birmingham,
and there's this old,
beautiful, Peabody Ford mansion,
it's called.
And it's on this corner.
And you look at it,
and it could have
been a lovely old
French restaurant
or American restaurant.
JASON ANDREAS:
Victorian-inspired.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah, exactly.
JASON ANDREAS: Our
office now is in Detroit,
but we used to be in Birmingham,
so we're two blocks from there.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So
you know where it is.
JASON ANDREAS: So we know
the mansion very well, yeah.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: And so
you walk in today, though,
and it's super cool
with this mural.
And I've got the music.
As I said, music's
important to me.
I do all the music for
all the restaurants.
And you walk in,
and you're changed
with this energy
that is unexpected,
which is what I like.
I always like a little
surprise here and there.
And we have a
fantastic chef that I
was able to hire named
Lloyd Roberts who is just
doing a beautiful job there
and making really consistent,
really good food.
But when I came to visit
them, when I first came here,
it was really with
the thought of,
like, I'm just going to
help out these friends
and give them some advice.
And advice turned into, well,
how about if you consult?
And consult turned into,
why don't you design?
And design has now
turned into, well,
why don't you manage
the property for us?
So the restaurant business
is a tough business.
It's a game of inches.
And so I'm happy to
be here, and we're
going to do more projects
with them, because we've had
such a good experience so far.
And the place is
packed, which is--
[KNOCKING]
--knock on some
metally, plastic thing--
that's it's really busy.
So I'm super happy with it.
JASON ANDREAS: That's great.
Well, congratulations.
And thanks for
considering Michigan.
The city of Detroit
in particular
has seen its ups and downs.
And food has been
a huge cornerstone
and a lot of the
reason that people
are moving back into the city.
So it's great to have you here.
What have you learned through
the process of consulting,
then now managing the
restaurant and adding it
to your portfolio?
What have you learned being in
the city of Detroit about kind
of what's going on in Detroit?
Have you found any
favorite restaurants?
What's your outlook now on
the city of Detroit, now
being part of the culture here?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So
it's a great question,
and I would say
the first thing I
tell people, anybody
who'll listen to me,
is that I do believe
having grown up
in Brooklyn that Detroit
is the next Brooklyn.
I really believe
that to be true.
And that's not some sort of
lip service because I'm here.
I believe that Detroit
and Brooklyn have
a certain odd synergy,
and I can't necessarily
nail what that
is, but I feel it.
There's this movement of young,
entrepreneurial, cool ideas,
creative-- you know, it's
all based around that.
But without that
Manhattan skyline,
which when you
lived in Brooklyn,
Manhattan always sort of got
center stage and be like, oh.
You live in Brooklyn.
Now it's, oh, you
live in Brooklyn?
It's cool now, you know?
It was never cool back
then, but now it's cool.
And Detroit was, I think for--
candidly, obviously,
for many, many years,
downtrodden and had gone
through such financial issues
and problems.
And now you see
this gentrification.
You have beautiful,
beautiful architecture here
people are taking advantage of.
The problem was
the buildings were
just empty and dilapidated.
But now they're
being brought back,
or new buildings are being done.
So there's this beautiful
very interesting to me
combination of old and new here.
You have a lot of chefs
that are coming out,
some that have Michigan roots.
So like Anthony from SheWolf.
I don't know if you guys have
been to that restaurant before,
but he just came to
visit me on Monday.
You know, I knew him
from Washington, DC.
And the fact that
he comes back here
and is just crushing it
with beautiful Italian food
and handmade pastas.
And you could be
in any major city
in the world and hope
for an experience
like you would get at SheWolf.
And so the one thing I would
say that's been surprising to me
is when I heard about Detroit,
I thought, oh, there's
going to be so many people
that will need jobs.
And that's not really the case.
The unemployment's
fairly low here.
And so the restaurants are
all, like in any other part
of the country, struggling
to fill all the positions.
But we've been lucky.
In Birmingham, we've got a
decent crew there that started.
You have a little
bit of turnover
at the beginning
of any restaurant.
But the crew that's there
today is really good.
So better and better and better.
The service has been good.
I've been to a bunch
of places here.
I got stuck here in
a blizzard last year.
JASON ANDREAS:
That happens, yeah.
MICHAEL SCHLOW:
Just a little note.
I'm not speaking
poorly about Detroit.
You can plow before
the snow ends.
[LAUGH]
It's allowed.
We do it in Boston all the
time, and it works out really,
really nicely.
But apparently here, they
wait till it stops snowing.
JASON ANDREAS: They do.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
But it snows a lot
here, doesn't it?
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, it does.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So
really piled up,
and nobody could go anywhere.
So I just walked everywhere
that I wanted to go to.
But I had great drinks
and a great experience
at Wright & Company,
Apparatus Room.
I'm trying to remember all
the places that I went to.
But it's been a great
experience here.
And the people are
nice here, you know?
I think where I grew up, there's
just an incredible amount
of sarcasm.
Everybody's so
sandwiched together.
Not that they're mean,
but there's a jab all
the time that's going on.
Your friends, your best
friends are the ones
that make fun of you, you know?
And I don't sense that
here in the same way.
You know, maybe it happens.
But I certainly get
the sense that people
are very, very nice to
each other and pleasant,
and it's lovely.
JASON ANDREAS: Still the
Midwest spirit we have here.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I
think that's nice.
I mean, probably the East Coast
could use a little bit of that
every once in a while.
JASON ANDREAS: Can you talk a
little bit more about Adachi
and kind of where the
inspiration came from?
I know that the proprietors
initially wanted
a Japanese-inspired restaurant.
Where did it go?
How did it go from just
this idea to Adachi?
What's the name represent?
What type of food did you decide
to bring into that restaurant?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So
one of the partners,
a guy named Ken Koza--
and Kenny is just a
great guy who just wants
to take care of everybody.
He owns all this stuff, and he's
in part of a family business.
But he singularly just said, I
really, for personal reasons,
want a Japanese-inspired
restaurant.
He had lived in Japan
for a little while,
and he was enamored by
the Adachi gardens there.
But also, Adachi's a
fairly common last name.
And he stayed with this
family for a little while
that their last name
was Adachi as well.
And he liked the sound of it,
and so there's a museum there.
There's the Adachi gardens.
And that was a name
he had always had.
And so when he came to me,
he said, can you do this?
So I said, I can do
this, but if I'm not
going to move to
the Detroit area,
we need to have a
killer chef, you know?
We need something that
really can understand
what I'm going to
tell them food-wise,
and then execute it
on a daily basis.
So I started to do
a search for staff,
but specifically for my chef.
And I wasn't getting the
responses that I had hoped for,
and I quite frankly was
like, I am fucked, you know?
Sorry for my language, but
I am totally screwed here.
And I don't know how I'm
going to pull this off,
because if I don't have the
right chef, I can't move there.
And what am I going to do?
Because my name's on the door.
I have to have the right person.
And so this resume
comes in from Indeed.
And I think somebody's
pulling my leg.
I think it's a joke.
And I read it, and
it comes from Dubai.
I was like, somebody
in Dubai's applying
for a job in Birmingham?
Somebody's messing with me.
And I look a little further,
and I say to my assistant,
you've got to set me up
with a Skype call for this.
Just email this person first.
See if they're
really interested.
And on the resume was
New York City, some
of my favorite restaurants.
Jean-Georges, the Modern
with Gabriel Kreuther
when he was the chef there.
Nobu, one downtown.
Then Nobu Fifty Seven.
And then it says,
this person who's
named Lloyd Roberts has
moved from Nobu Fifty Seven
and is the executive chef
of Nobu Budapest, then
Nobu Moscow, and
then goes to Dubai
to become the executive
chef of Wakame in Dubai.
And I just think it's a total--
you know, somebody's
playing with me.
So then we set up a Skype call.
And now I'm really convinced
that somebody's playing
with me, because
on my Skype call
is this large African American
man who was born in Jamaica.
And I'm like, OK.
Who are you?
He's like, I'm Lloyd Roberts.
And I was like, all right.
Let's start talking.
And I immediately fall
in love with the guy.
He's so sweet, so nice,
but super talented.
And we start talking
about food, and he
understands everything I say.
Like, that doesn't
happen every time.
You know, sometimes
I'll bring something up,
and somebody's like, I
don't know about that.
He knew everything.
And we had sort of similar
parallel lines in New York.
And I said, well, I can't fly
to Dubai to taste your food.
And do you want to move
back to the States?
He has two kids and he
met his wife in Russia,
I believe, or maybe
when he was in England.
I can't remember where they met.
But he said, we want to
come back to the States,
but I don't want to work in New
York, San Francisco, Chicago.
I don't want to
be in a big city.
I said, oh, have I
got the place for you.
I said, this is
going to be great.
I've got this great town where
you can bring your kids up.
Your kids can run around,
and you're going to love it.
And I convinced him to look this
place up and talk to people.
And he moved--
I hired him without
tasting his food,
and he moved here without
ever seeing Birmingham.
JASON ANDREAS: Wow.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Which
is crazy, right?
And so he gets here,
and the restaurant's
delayed a little bit, so I
bring him to Washington, DC,
and we start to do pop-ups in my
restaurants to promote Adachi.
And they sell out one after
another after another.
And there was an
immediate synergy
and understanding as
soon as we got together,
and I'm so proud of him.
Today there was this
beautiful review
that we got in one
of the local papers.
And when we saw
each other today,
we just hugged each other.
And we're so proud of
what they're doing.
And he was working in all these
major cities, and he said, oh.
And he's got this great accent.
It's like a little
bit of Jamaica,
a little bit of New York
City, a little bit of London,
and then something else that
I can't figure out what it is,
but it's mixed together.
And when I talk to him
on the phone sometimes,
he'll say, oh, chef--
and I can hear--
even though we're on the phone,
I know he's shaking his head.
I goes, I'm not in New
York anymore, am I?
I said, no, you're not.
You have to treat-- and
every place is different.
And everybody eats differently,
funny enough, you know?
That's another thing that's
sort of worth talking about.
I can put the most popular
dish on, say, Alta Strada, one
of our Italian
restaurants, on every menu,
and it won't necessary
become the most popular dish
in other restaurants.
And I find that
sort of fascinating.
Like, what sells
in Washington, DC
may not sell in
Wellesley, Massachusetts,
and it may not sell in LA.
But what sells in
LA won't necessarily
sell in the other places also.
So that's sort of fascinating
to watch how people eat
and how they behave.
Obviously, the people here
are the best behaved people.
[LAUGH]
JASON ANDREAS:
Couldn't agree more.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yes.
JASON ANDREAS: Well, thank you
for all of that information.
And yes, the reviews have
been awesome on Adachi.
Thank you, again, for
considering Detroit.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Except for--
can I ask you--
Google doesn't-- they
don't own Yelp, do they?
JASON ANDREAS: No, we don't.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: OK, good.
JASON ANDREAS: I was
going to get there, too.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Let's do--
let's talk about Yelp.
Let's talk about Yelp.
JASON ANDREAS: So you
gave a glowing review
of Google technology
helping you and your staff,
so thank you for that.
I'll slip you the
$50 bucks I owe you.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I only need $5.
It's fine.
JASON ANDREAS: OK.
Normally, I give $50.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Oh, $50's good.
OK.
JASON ANDREAS: No, $5.
We've got it on film.
But thank you for that.
And we obviously try
and make people's lives
easier through some of
the technology we have.
And technology in general is,
I guess, supposed to do that.
But when we have chefs
and restaurateurs in,
we always get this conversation.
How do you deal with the
positives of technology
with also some of the challenges
that reservation apps and food
delivery services now--
the folks aren't even
going out as much anymore,
because they're just
having food delivered to them.
So what's the balance that
you find between the positives
that you have with also some
of the challenges that you also
have to consider now
that maybe you didn't
have to consider 20 years ago?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: You didn't
have to consider those things.
Right.
I mean, takeout was
you called up and said,
I'll have a quart of
hot and sour soup,
and you went and got it, and
that was the end of it, right?
So all this is an
ever-changing world,
and we have a few people on our
team that specialize in this.
And so they stay
current on this.
There's a couple of things
that the end result user,
the guest probably
doesn't even know.
Like, when you call, for
example, Uber Eats or Caviar,
the rev share on
that as an example
is not a good model
for the restaurateur.
We're already dealing
with really slim margins.
And so when Uber Eats, for
example, or somebody like that,
a company like that--
I don't mean to name
them specifically,
but they're very popular--
A, I can't control the product.
I don't know.
If you're the Uber driver and
you come and pick that up,
I don't know how long
you are leaving that,
say, sushi in the
backseat of your car
before you bring it over to
the person that ordered it.
So I can't control the
product once it leaves.
But also, the rev
share is a percentage
that I don't really
understand the model.
And when you think about
Uber as an example, which
I use all the time and
I love the product,
the product is I'm charged
based on how far I go, right?
JASON ANDREAS: Right.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So
you get in the car
and you're going
this far, it's $10.
You go that far, it's $20.
And you go that much
further, it's $30, right?
But for Uber Eats, they charge
me based on how much you order.
Not how far they
have to drive it.
So if you're just
going across the street
and you order $200 worth of
food, I have to give them $60.
30%.
If you order $10 worth of food
and you're going 10 blocks,
I only have to give them $3.
That part doesn't
make any sense to me.
So if you're watching, Uber
Eats, let's work on that.
We can work on that one.
The systems, though,
of making sure
that you are technologically
easy for the--
is also very important.
So making sure the
apps that we have,
the online ordering
apps are super
fast and super easy
and not too complicated
I think is a big play.
Because I know when I'm
doing it for-- you know,
if I'm going to order something
for my wife and kids online--
and I don't shop from clothes
online or things like that.
My wife does, but I don't.
I still go to a store and I want
to touch the pants or whatever
it is, and feel them and try
stuff on, because I'm too lazy.
I don't want to send it
back if it doesn't fit.
JASON ANDREAS:
It's too much work.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
Just don't take it out
of the store, you know?
And then you don't
have to bring it back.
But for food, which
you can't return,
I want to make sure that
it's super easy for people.
And so that if they are
doing it-- but I mean,
if they want delivery,
they want delivery.
And you know, there's that ease.
But part of the
beauty of a restaurant
is that interaction,
that social interaction
that even if it's just with
the bartender or the waiter
or somebody and
you're not eating
in your house, over your
computer, watching TV,
whatever-- there's times
for that, of course.
But I also think that one of
the things that we provide
is that social interaction--
JASON ANDREAS: Experience.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
So it makes it so interesting.
The part about reviews,
when I was a young cook
and when I started in the
business, and even as my career
sort of kept going, there
were certainly plenty
of times where I thought, OK.
There's a food
critic, and you have
to take care of
that food critic,
because that food critic
yielded incredible power.
And so in "The New York
Times" if Ruth Reichl or--
I'm going way back.
Bryan Miller, whoever
it might have been
wrote a good review,
that restaurant
was busy for years off
of that good review.
And the reality is that you all
have the power of the pen now.
It's different.
So you go on Yelp and
say, this place sucked.
I'm never going back there.
My food-- it didn't come
out for seven minutes.
My first thing is I'm
thinking like, all right.
Well, what could you make
at home in seven minutes
that you're getting
mad at me for?
But we have a
certain expectation
when we go out to
dinner that the food's
going to be delivered in a
prompt, reasonable amount
of time.
And what I would
say to anybody who's
going to write a review
online is, did you
give the operator
the opportunity
to fix whatever the issues are?
Now nobody ever came
over and said, hi.
I want to come over
and check and see--
I hope you enjoyed your meal.
We've all done this before.
I've done it for sure, and
that is, how's everything?
It's good.
It's fine.
Everything's great.
JASON ANDREAS: Thanks.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: And yeah.
And then you walk out.
They're like, well, that sucked.
I'm never going
back there again.
Give the person a
chance to fix it.
So some of my favorite
Yelp or Google reviews
are the ones where
somebody said,
you know, we had an
issue with blank,
but the manager came over
or the chef came over,
and they fixed it.
That's the opportunity to
really win over a guest
for a long period
of time is when
you have those opportunities
presented to themselves.
Did you act on it?
But everybody's a critic
now, and they always were.
They just have way more power.
But when somebody
says, like, I'm
going to go online
and write a review,
and I'm going to ruin
you, it's like, OK.
It's food, you know?
We're just trying--
it's a human business.
There's going to
be error at times.
We try to minimize those errors.
But when there is
an error, we make
sure that we go above
and beyond, anything
that we could do
normally to make
sure you had a good experience.
And in reverse, when somebody
writes something glowing
and something really nice, we
make sure we reach out as well
and say, hey.
Thank you so much.
I'm glad you enjoyed it.
Please say hello
next time you're in.
And again, it's about connection
more than anything else.
JASON ANDREAS: Reviews aside,
because there is some--
other than the participation
you just mentioned,
there is some lack
of control there,
which is what they're meant to
be, I suppose, from the ground
up, when we go back to some
of the other technology
like the reservation systems,
like the food delivery,
we've talked to some chefs,
and I've read a few articles
where some newer restaurants are
actually shying away from that.
So they're not
participating in technology
from a reservation perspective.
You have to actually pick up the
phone and call the restaurant.
And they're not participating
in delivery because--
whether it's issues
with rev share or just
losing control of the food
between pickup and delivery
to the person who's ordered it.
Have you ever thought
about something like that,
or is it too important
to the community
to stay involved in that?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Especially
with the reservation system,
it is an ongoing conversation
and ongoing, like, battle,
basically.
You have one 800-pound
gorilla in OpenTable.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: And
there's almost this threat
that you feel--
not by them.
As an operator, you
feel this pressure.
I sort of have to
go with them, right?
Because if you're scrolling
and you're in a new city
and you're looking at OpenTable
for restaurants in my area
where I want Italian food and
you're scrolling and scrolling
and we're not on
OpenTable, does that
mean you're never
going to find us?
How are you going to find us?
And so there's that fear.
Well, OpenTable, which
is a great system--
it provides a service, for sure.
But there's a cost
to us as well.
And it's not as simple as
just one size fits all.
If you make the
reservation on OpenTable
through my website, the
restaurant's website,
it costs $0.25 per guest.
If you make it through
OpenTable, it's $1 per guest.
So I'm not sure why, but it is.
And so when you see
the checks that I
write to OpenTable
every single month,
you start to scratch your head
and say, is this worth it?
Because it's a lot of money.
But they provide a service,
and they provide information
to you.
And so I could find
out, you know, oh, Jason
ate in this
restaurant 400 times.
It's time we bought
Jason a meal, you know?
Or it's his birthday.
They give you a lot
of good information,
so you're paying for that too.
So there's a couple of
other systems out there
that are interesting,
and they're
a little bit more
cost-effective,
but they're not
as big, and so you
don't have some of the
bandwidth that OpenTable has.
But it's an interesting
conversation,
and I'm not sure where
it will ultimately go.
For us right now, we have
OpenTable in our restaurants.
Now a funny thing is
at Adachi, we don't.
But Adachi's really small.
It's 65 seats.
And we leave half of the
restaurant for reservations
and half for walk-ins.
So going back to
community, I want
you to feel like you
can walk in at any time
and hopefully get a table.
Luckily, it's been really
busy, so the first people that
walk in get the table, and
then so everybody else has
to wait a little bit.
But it seems like
it's a fair way
to do it that half the
restaurant's for reservation
and half is not.
JASON ANDREAS: It's
finding a balance, right?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I'm
trying to, you know?
And the end of
the day, listen, I
have a financial,
fiduciary responsibility
to the investors,
to the business
itself to make sure
that we're making
as much money as possible.
But you have a
responsibility to your guests
to provide a really enjoyable
experience and not just think--
you don't want your
guests to ever think
it's just about the money.
Like, when you come and see
the fish that we have there,
it's pristine.
It's perfect.
It's as good a fish as
I could possibly get.
And it's been one of the
overriding comments, which
I'm really happy about.
So if you like sushi and
sashimi, you come there,
and the first thing
I've heard over and over
and over again is, where
are you getting this from?
Because this is really
spectacular fish.
So that makes us feel good
that the guest is recognizing
the quality of the product.
And you know, over
a course of time,
if you can continue to do that,
you'll build up a loyal base.
JASON ANDREAS: Right.
I want to go back to
something, because I'd
be remiss not to touch on this.
I let it go by earlier,
but I've been thinking
about coming back to it.
And I'm using
technology as a bridge,
because we talked about
technology just now.
You've done some YouTube videos,
some how-tos, things like that,
which are really fun.
And you also have a
great website, truly.
And I found some really
interesting stuff
on your website that
you touched on earlier.
You talked about how much
you enjoy music and travel.
You've got two sections
on your website.
One is for travel
recommendations.
So let's say you go to Portland.
Here's a bunch of places
that you recommend.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I'm
doing a terrible job
of keeping up with it.
To be honest with you,
I love what's on there.
JASON ANDREAS: This
is the reminder.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Well,
I'm going to do it.
JASON ANDREAS: Let's
get a Detroit one.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah, OK.
For sure.
I'll definitely
get a Detroit one.
I suck at keeping up on it.
And we're redoing my website,
keeping the same ideas
but revamping the look of it.
JASON ANDREAS: Great.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Because thank
you for your compliments,
but I think it needs to
look a little different,
and we haven't kept up with it.
So music.
Like, I have this thing.
Music to cook with.
Like, download this stuff,
and you turn the music on.
JASON ANDREAS: That's
where I was going.
That's my favorite section.
I love to cook with my wife,
and we always throw music on
while we're doing so.
And I followed some of yours,
and they're quite good.
They really are.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I need
to update that too,
because there's a lot of music.
I mean, some of it's older
music and some of it's newer.
But one of the things--
I wrote a book years ago
called "It's About Time."
And the subtitle is
"Recipes for Everyday Life."
And what the book was
about was that I realized--
and we could talk
about technology
and fold this into
the conversation
is that I was doing some
research for the book.
I didn't want to write a book
that was about appetizer,
soups, salad, entre, or
the seasons, or about me.
I mean, I had to
put me in it, but it
wasn't going to be this
egotistical chef's tome
that was going to sit
on your coffee table,
and nobody was ever
going to cook from it.
I wanted something that
you were going to use.
And so at the time
I wasn't married,
and I was watching my sister,
who has a bunch of kids.
And she was literally running
a mini restaurant in her house.
And she's like, Zachary,
what do you want for dinner?
Joshua, what are you having?
I was like, what is this?
You know, what are you,
a short order cook?
I'm like, what are you doing?
When we were kids, there was
one meal that everybody had,
and there was no ordering.
The only ordering
was on your birthday,
and that's where you ordered
something that your brothers
and sisters didn't like
so that you could torture
them a little bit, right?
And so I started to come
up with this notion of,
time is the most precious
commodity we have.
Nobody has enough
of it, and we're all
trying to make more of it.
And food, other than for
just basic sustenance,
is the center of our day.
You know, things happen
around the table.
And whether it's the
morning coffee table,
it's the dinner table--
you know, for my family,
6:30, quarter to 7:00,
your ass was in that
seat, and you'd better
be ready, because
dinner's coming,
and everybody had to be in it.
And there was no getting
up early or anything.
That's where we learned
about how to behave
and how to talk about
politics just in general
was at my parents'
kitchen table.
And we don't have that
anymore, you know?
It's sort of gone
from everyday life.
It's a rare treat.
And so I thought,
why not write a book
that the chapters
be broken into,
what's happening to you today?
What do you need
today from food?
And so it's everything
from a chapter on speed,
in getting food on the
table in 30 minutes or less,
to all the way
through where it's
time to celebrate and relax,
and turn off your phone
and turn off your computer
and turn on the music,
and open up a bottle
of wine and cook
for the basic tactile
pleasure, the smells.
Everybody's got
that certain thing
that takes you back
to either grandma's
house or your mother's house.
And you're like, ah.
The smell of a roasted
lemon garlic chicken
makes me think of my
grandmother's house.
And so when I was
doing this book,
I was looking up things that
I could find that maybe I
could throw into the book that
were different pieces that
were written a long time ago.
And I didn't include
this in the book,
but I always talk about it.
There was this article
that was from the late '50s
or early '60s.
Sort of a Jules
Verne kind of thing
that's said, by the year 2000--
[LAUGH]
--you know, by the year 2000,
automation and technology
will do everything for us, that
the average American will only
have to work 20 hours a week.
And I thought, well, that would
have been great, you know?
It's quite the opposite.
JASON ANDREAS: We're
about 4x that right now.
Yeah.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: But
that is because I
think the one part
about technology
is we continue to use it
to become more productive.
And so we're never
turned off anymore.
You know, when our parents
were off for the weekends,
they were off, you know?
When my father
came home from work
and the phone rang when we
were at the dinner table,
my father would
pick it up and say,
Michael's having
dinner right now.
Call back at 7:30, and
hang up on my friends.
Sometimes he didn't
even say goodbye.
He'd just hang up on them.
And that's just different.
Like, the phone rings and
me or my wife or-- you
know, we're always, oh, sorry.
I'll be right back.
I've got to take this.
We don't really have to take
it, but we're like Pavlov's dog.
The thing buzzes in our
pocket, and we like, ah,
I've got to answer it.
And I'm not sure why we
did that to ourselves.
And what we've done
is the technology
is great, because we
are more productive
and we get more stuff done.
But we're never
stopping, and it's
hard to turn your brain off now.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
It's balance, right?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Well, you
need it, and I don't have it.
I mean--
JASON ANDREAS: Most of us don't.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
[LAUGH]
I don't have it.
But at the same token--
but I'm happy, you know?
I mean, I love the feeling
of getting stuff done.
And all of the different things
that I use for keeping track--
you know, when you
check something off,
there's a sense
of accomplishment.
The list is long, but
every time you can say, oh,
I just got six things done--
you know, I'm in the car.
What am I doing?
I'm working.
I'm in the car.
I'm not relaxing.
I'm not taking a nap, you know?
Getting stuff done.
JASON ANDREAS: I love your
idea from the cookbook
and also just kind
of in general,
the idea of food being
a staple of the day
and bringing things together,
bringing people together.
Food is huge at Google, right?
Everyone, the first
question I always
get when people find
out I work at Google,
oh, you guys get free food?
We do, and it's amazing.
A shout out to our team.
One of the reasons that that
was done from very early on,
though, is as a part of the
day to bring people together.
Especially in
today's day and age
where you're working
80 hours a week,
it's so easy just to bring a
sandwich, sit at your desk,
and keep working.
Whereas if you've got delicious
food just down the hall
and you can smell it wafting
through the hallways,
it's much easier for me to
grab a couple of my teammates.
Say, hey, let's go
have a lunch meeting.
Let's sit there for an hour.
Let's actually just enjoy the
food and talk and catch up.
And some of Google's
best ideas have
come about over lunch
meetings that maybe you
wouldn't have had if you
didn't have that food.
So it is a fantastic perk, and
we're very lucky to have it.
But there's also some
meaning behind it as well.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I
think that's great.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm in
the food business,
so I wish you came
to our restaurants
instead of staying here
for your lunch meetings.
[LAUGH]
I'm teasing you.
I think it's very
cool that Google--
JASON ANDREAS: You said
65 seats in Adachi?
We've got about-- roughly about
65 Googlers in this office.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Well,
what we should do is--
why don't we do one day?
Why don't I come here and
cook you all lunch one day?
AUDIENCE: Yes!
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Why
don't we do that?
JASON ANDREAS: You guys in?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
[LAUGH]
I would love to do that.
That's easy.
JASON ANDREAS: We
would never say no.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: No, I mean,
I did that-- it was funny.
You had mentioned Cond Nast.
But way back when, I used
to go once in a while,
and they had this chef for
the day kind of thing in Cond
Nast.
And I would go there and
cook something for them.
And that was hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds
of people, so it
was kind of crazy.
But 65 people, we could
come and have some fun.
Yeah.
That would be good.
I'd be happy to do that.
That would be fun.
JASON ANDREAS: We'll
take you up on that.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: But
food, it's the connector.
And you know, I feel bad for
people that don't like food.
You know, when people say,
like, yeah, it's not my thing,
you know?
I eat.
I like to-- but again,
just to fill their belly.
Like, I'm into it.
Like, I dream about it.
I think about it.
When I'm planning my
travels, it's all about food.
And my wife, my wife likes food.
My kids like food.
But I mean, I'm obsessed.
So yeah, it's not probably
healthy to the point
that I'm obsessed about it.
But I haven't been able
to keep up with it.
You talk about
technology, but there's
been some changes in
traditional periodicals
that we've lost, unfortunately,
over the course of time because
of technology.
And so you no longer
in your restaurants
get-- like, there was a
magazine called "Food Arts."
And when the "Food
Arts" would come,
everybody would fight over
who got to read it first,
because it also kept you up
to date on who was moving,
who was changing, who was
going where, who was making
the latest and greatest things.
And I would play a game
with myself to say,
I am going to know where every
chef that's in "Food Arts"
is headed to.
I'm doing this thing in San
Diego in the next month,
and it's the San Diego
Food and Wine Festival.
And I'm part of this
week-long celebration
of different things.
So there were all
these names that
got sent to me as to who the
participating chefs were.
And I sent to my
assistant, I said,
I only know three
of these names.
And that was upsetting
to me that I didn't
know who these people were.
And so I said to my assistant,
here's what I want you to do.
I want you to Google
every single one of them
and send me a little report.
Not long.
Just a couple
sentences so I can look
at, know where they came
from, where they work,
and who they are so
that I don't look like,
A, that I'm ignorant when I
walk in there to say, oh, hi.
Where are you from?
And instead, how
nice is it to be
able to be recognized
by a peer--
in this case, me--
that I know what you're doing.
I know what you're up to.
It always made me
feel good when I
was a young cook, a young
chef to go to these events
and somebody said,
oh, Michael, yes.
You know, Cafe Louis, Boston.
I've just read about you.
I've been dying to come try your
restaurant, or whatever it is.
It makes you feel good.
The peer-to-peer thing is really
important in our industry.
Not just being
recognized, because you
don't have to be recognized.
But any man or woman
that is willing to put
on the white jacket and cook and
sit over a hot stove, you know,
80 hours a week, there's
a fraternity, a club,
whatever you want to call it
that you immediately belong to.
And it's a lovely thing
to be able to go anywhere
in the country or anywhere
in the world for that matter
and say, yeah, I'm a chef.
They don't have to
know the restaurant.
Immediately, a little
something extra comes out.
There's that
professional courtesy.
It's beautiful.
I was in Italy last year.
I was in this little
tiny town, and there
was a woman running around
this restaurant by herself.
She didn't have any help.
And I speak enough Italian
that I was talking to her.
And she's running around.
I had ordered a bottle
of wine with the people
that I was sitting with.
And I knew she was too busy to
even open the bottle of wine,
because she was by herself.
And I said to her,
you know, here.
I'll help you.
Give me the bottle of wine.
I'll open it for myself.
And she's like, no, no, no.
I was like, it's OK.
Go do your thing.
So when the night cleared
out and we were by ourselves,
basically, me, my colleagues
that I was traveling with,
and the woman--
so she says-- she didn't
speak any English.
And she's like,
where are you from?
And I told her,
the United States,
and I'm in the
restaurant business.
And she's like, oh.
That's why you opened
the wine for me.
You know that I was in
the weeds, you know,
which is the term.
And next thing I know, her
dad comes out of the kitchen,
this old man.
And I said, oh, can we
go back in the kitchen?
I'm looking.
I'm like, where-- and
the food was delicious.
I'm like, where's your cooks?
Where's your-- oh, no.
It's just me and my daughter.
And the two of them
ran this restaurant,
and they did 16 tables
every single night.
Now 16 tables, I
would never allow
one server to have 16 tables.
But they got away
with it somehow,
and the food was delicious,
and everybody loved it.
But that connection immediately.
Like, oh.
You're in the
restaurant business?
And that part's really great.
I love that part.
JASON ANDREAS: You had
mentioned music and getting
to meet some of your idols as
to rock stars, things like that.
As a last question, I
guess, any rock star moments
in doing some travel with some
of these folks, or anything
that you can share with us?
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
I mean, there's--
[LAUGH]
I'd be gloating.
I don't want to make you--
well, it's weird, because
these people become friends.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, sure.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So when you
say their names, you're like,
you're friends with them?
It's weird, because when
I see them on stage,
they're my friends doing
what they do for a living,
just like when I think they come
see me cook, I'm just cooking.
So some of my highlights,
there's a lot of them,
but great moments would
be traveling through Italy
with REM.
They're dear friends
of mine, so getting
to see Michael Stipe and
Mike Mills and Peter Buck,
and traveling literally
from Venice all the way down
to Naples for a couple weeks
with them, that was cool.
When I lived in New
York-- and we're
still dear friends
with Billy Joel.
And you know, you
get a shout out
when he says, like,
this is for Michael.
"Scenes From An
Italian Restaurant"
he sings, and you're
like, what just happened?
JASON ANDREAS: Is that me?
[LAUGH]
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Like,
Michael who, you know?
But I've gotten to meet
all of my rock heroes
and become friendly with them.
I'm friends with the guys
from U2 and The Stones.
JASON ANDREAS: These
are not small rock bands
you're talking about.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: No, no, no.
They're big ones.
Yeah.
And it's all through
food, though.
That's how we met,
was through food.
And they would joke
and say, listen.
There were times
in our lives where
we would sing for our suppers.
And all the rockers
say the same thing.
Sing for their supper.
It's just, I guess, a line.
JASON ANDREAS: Maybe
that's the connection.
Working at bars, you
sing for your drinks
and suppers back in the
day, and it was always
a special part of it.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I think so.
JASON ANDREAS: It's interesting.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: So I've
gotten to meet all of them
and become friends with them.
And there's times where
we won't see each other
for a year or two,
but if they're either
blowing through town or I'm
somewhere where they might be,
I'll go see them.
And I often would bring food
backstage for after the show.
Or if they were staying
in a hotel or something,
we'd go cook at that hotel.
JASON ANDREAS: Maybe
that's the key.
If we put Chef
Schlow on the list,
we'll give him free tickets,
he'll bring food for us.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Basically,
that's what I was.
JASON ANDREAS: Everyone wins.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Well,
there's one story where
I was only, like,
24 or 25 years old,
and I was living
out in East Hampton,
Long Island, which is
where Billy Joel lived.
And he called me up one day,
and he was out on the road.
And he would go
to this restaurant
that I was the chef
at three times a week.
Especially in the off season,
he'd go three times a week.
And he said, hey,
you know-- we had
become a little friendly at
that point, but not friends,
friends.
We just knew each other fairly
well, but nothing crazy.
And he calls up one
day, and I thought
he was home and wanted
something special.
So the kitchen phone rings,
and they said, hey, Michael.
Billy Joel's on
the phone for you.
I'm like, sure he is, you know?
I was like, no, he's not.
I'd answer the phone,
and his voice is on it.
He's like, hey, Michael.
It's Billy Joel.
I'm like, oh my God.
It really is Billy Joel.
I was like, hey.
Yes?
What can I do for you?
What's up?
And he said, well,
I'm wondering.
He goes, we're out on the road,
and to be honest with you,
we don't get fed very well.
Like, so a big star
like that, you know,
when you go backstage, he
would never eat before a show,
and they didn't have a lot of--
they had catering everything,
but he didn't want to eat that.
And when you get done with the
show, especially when they were
all earlier on in
their careers and they
would play longer encores
and things like that,
everything's closed.
So you're stuck with
room service in a hotel.
You get back to the
room at 11:30 at night.
So he said, do you have
a day off next week?
And I said, yeah, I think I'm
off Tuesday and Wednesday.
Why?
And here I'm, like,
muffled, going, hey, Max.
Where are we next
Tuesday and Wednesday?
And it was like, Albany or
Buffalo or something like that.
It was Albany, in fact, the
first time I ever did this.
And he said, would you
consider coming to our show?
You know, come see the
show and everything,
but we could cook
dinner afterwards.
I was like, of course
I would do that.
That would be amazing, right?
So I flew to Albany
with all, like, 300
pounds of food or something.
And I was a kid--
as I said, I'm by myself.
And this is before technology,
so I can't record it.
I don't have a cell
phone back then.
There's no cell phones.
And I'm sitting up
on the riser where
the soundboard is and the
lighting board and everything.
And I'm sitting up there,
minding my own business,
and the guys are like, would
you like a beer or something
to drink?
I was like, yeah, sure.
I'll go get a beer.
They're like, no, no.
We'll have it brought to you.
And I'm thinking I'm going to
get, like, a bad stadium beer,
you know?
And this metal tub comes down
with all these cold beers.
And I was like, this
is nice up here.
Chh!
And I'd have a beer.
And he starts to play.
And halfway through the
show, he literally--
I'll never forget this
for the rest of my life.
He asked the audience,
did everybody
have a nice dinner tonight?
And they cheered
for whatever reason.
He said, oh.
He said, well, I never
eat before a show.
And he's, like, just
playing on the keys
and he's fooling around.
And I have no idea
what he's going to do.
And he said, if you ever get
to Long Island-- he goes,
that's where I live.
He said, my friend
Michael's here today.
And I'm like-- and I
still don't think it's me.
[LAUGH]
And he said, he is the chef at
my favorite restaurant called
Sapore di Mare.
And we're going to have it all.
And he starts to list all
the things that I brought.
He starts telling
people, we're going
to have spaghetti aglio,
olio con pomodoro.
We're going to
have broccoli rabe.
We're going to have
all this stuff.
And he starts to literally
list the menu that I brought.
And he's like, I can't wait.
So Michael, thanks for coming.
And then he plays "Scenes
From An Italian Restaurant."
I'm like, there's nobody here
to validate this and verify
that this actually happened.
Nobody's going to
believe me, you know?
And then years
later, he would play,
and I would always get a nice
little shout out or something.
Then I did have a cell
phone, and my cell phone
would just be like--
[BUZZING]
Did you just get a shout
out at Gillette Stadium?
So that to me--
and you can hear it
in my voice hopefully
is that one of the
great pleasures
is getting to meet
my musical heroes,
becoming friendly with them,
and getting to feed them.
And there's something amazing
about that, because I'm
in awe of musicians.
I don't play an instrument,
but I love music so much.
And I'm constantly listening
to music, surrounded by it,
thinking about how it
interacts with your experience
in the restaurants.
I think the restaurants
are absolutely
a five-sense experience.
It's not just what
you eat, but it
is what you see,
what you hear, what
you smell, what you put your
hands on, everything like that.
And so for me to be able
to meet them and then
play some of their music
once in a while when it's
appropriate in our
different restaurants,
there's a pride there that's
sort of difficult to explain
sometimes.
But that is a very,
very cool part
of what I've been able to do.
JASON ANDREAS: Well, they say
music is a great connector.
Food is a great connector.
I feel like they go
hand-in-hand very well together.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: I do too.
You know, I have
a friend of mine
who-- we were talking
about different rock stars.
But a guy named
Peter Wolf, who is
the lead singer of The J. Geils
Band, is a dear friend of mine.
And he lives in Boston.
And he's also sort
of mixed media.
He's a painter also.
He's a poet.
He does all sorts of things.
Really interesting guy.
And he's one of those people
that really understands
about food and people and
connecting them, and trying
to do it also through music.
But also just relationships.
You know, listen.
Every business-- doesn't matter
if it's Google, restaurants,
the music business--
every business has
really wonderful people
in it, and every business
has some assholes in it, right?
So the trick is to
weed out the assholes
and make sure you're dealing
with the best people--
JASON ANDREAS: Words to live by.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
Weed out the-- if there's one
thing I'm going to leave you
with, weed out the assholes.
JASON ANDREAS: We can
title the talk that.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Yeah.
[LAUGH]
JASON ANDREAS: Perfect.
Well, Chef, thank you
so much for coming.
I can talk about this
forever, literally.
Maybe we can share
some time afterwards.
Or there's no question.
We will take you up
on the opportunity
to have you come and join us.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: And if
anybody has questions,
I don't have to be
anywhere for a few minutes.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
Great.
Well, thank you so
much for coming in.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Thank you.
JASON ANDREAS:
Thank you so much.
MICHAEL SCHLOW: Real pleasure.
Thanks.
JASON ANDREAS: Thank you.